the sunday sag awards they're back to
being in person for the first time since
2020 it feels like forever and despite
the strict protocols that are in place
the stars are ready to return to the red
carpet
i've never met will smith before and i
just feel like he's
like my dad or like i want him to be my
dad he's going to say they all want will
smith to be aired down yes
sag ambassadors alexandra d'addario from
the white lotus and ross butler from 13
reasons why are ready to fan out as lady
gaga leo denzel and many more will be
here inside barker hangar for sunday's
award show airing on tnt and tbs ross's
shazam co-star helen mirren will receive
the lifetime achievement award like she
just comes on set of shazam in her
costume and she's just elegant but funny
and what will celebs like andrew
garfield and nicole kidman dine on
there's drinks of course and chef curtis
stone is preparing 700 dishes featuring
salmon and vegetables we don't use
gluten we don't use um any sort of dairy
products so we're using ingredients that
everybody can eat
[Music]
you